general Keith Alexander is a decorated
military veteran who ran the NSA for the
last eight and a half years during that
time he faced questioning from the
highest-ranking officials in the land
but now he would face the opposite of
that so first general thank you so much
for sitting down with me looking back on
your time at the NSA do you have any
regrets such as not retiring one year
earlier you know I thought about that
and you know at times you think if I had
just retired somebody else would have
had this burden it would have been wrong
for me to leave that for somebody else
to do do you think that the NSA is
suffering from a perception problem with
the American people at the moment
barring them onto the answer to that is
yes absolutely you know the first
assumption is that you're collecting on
the American people and therein lies the
problem because the true reality is the
target is not the American people know
the target is not the American people
but it seems the too often you miss the
target and you hit the American person
standing next to a go whoa whoa him but
you see we're not just out there
gathering US communications listening to
their phone calls or collecting their
emails but that's the first thing that
people jump to but you are out there
doing that you're just saying you're not
then reading them you are gathering that
right no no so in terms of going after
US infrastructure or sitting here in the
United States you know talking to a and
B talking in the United States we aren't
collecting that we don't collect that we
do collect a metadata a to from number
date time group and duration of a call
that's all that's in there but that's
not nothing no that's not significant
information otherwise you wouldn't want
it is this the argument then to to get
the needle you need to haystack well
that's part of the argument right but
people's concerns I think are that
you're not just taking the haystack
you're taking the whole farm or and the
county and the state and you've now got
some photos of the farmer's wife in the
shower as well so
si is not allowed to go do that on and
so on it has oversight and so what the
courts Congress and the administration
do is say if you're going to do this it
has to comport with the Constitution so
the question I think the American people
really have to ask is are we doing the
right things to protect the nation and
our civil liberties and privacy I am the
biggest advocate of freedom of the
networks Internet and if we could come
up with a way of segregating all the
terrorist communications when it would
be it would really help us and protect
our civil liberties and privacy and you
know there was a great statement by
somebody you could probably get this
into a part of that you know what we
really need to do is all the bad guys
need to be on this section of the
Internet and they only operate up here
all good people operate over here all
bad guys over here are you talking about
Pinterest no I'm you know bad guy oh I
thought I thought you meant all the
worst people in the world in one area so
I thought you were talking about
Pinterest because that seems to be where
they kind of assemble oh could be they
are the worst people oh look I look I've
found this gopher bedspread I'd love
that
shut up shut up so I've not seen that
that's what you haven't seen as director
of the NSA you haven't seen Pinterest
that's right so that's where the
terrorist could have been hiding all
these in isolated sheltered life how
much data do you need to keep Americans
safe that's a tough tough question I
don't know the answer to that here's
what I do know I look at the last 12
years 13 years since 9/11 we've had a
tremendous and remarkable record that
wasn't by accident but you're always
going to err on the side on you in your
position of wanting more rather than
less to be safe well absolutely in the
court is going to take just the opposite
view and say do you have the necessary
rationale for having this data that's
what I'm saying so those two principles
of the NSA are built to clash you have
one side saying let's take everything
you have one side saying let's protect
privacy those two things don't work
together well they actually you have to
bow
watch them but I think you can do both
it's been said that your motto was
collect everything is that true for
specific problems right but you do
understand that collect everything is
also the motto of a hoarder that's the
fundamental principle which ends up with
someone living alongside 1,500 copies of
newspapers in the 1950s and six momen
five cats what I would tell you is let's
go to where that statement applied Iraq
and the situation was 2006 and the issue
was the number of casualties for us and
our allies was rising in your mind has
the NSA ever done something illegal in
my time no not that I know of you know
one of the most impressive things that
I've seen in my career was people who
have made a mistake that could be a huge
mistake stepping up to say I made a
mistake
and in every case to my knowledge
everyone except for 12 individuals step
forward at the time they made those
mistakes right but you can't say
everyone except for 12 but that that's
not saying I've never killed anyone
apart from those three people that I
have buried under my patio at home the
issue is I think the key issue is that I
was trying to make is in every case we
reported in some cases those who made a
mistake didn't report but we're still
caught why should the American people
trust the NSA well from my perspective
because of what they do to protect this
country every day these are good people
trying to do the right thing but much of
your reassurance there is based on your
own moral code the idea of you thinking
what I wouldn't abuse this power so why
would anyone else I would I would if I
had access to that kind of information
I would abuse the hell out of it I'll be
looking up information about everyone
that I knew I know that everybody who
goes through the training they'd say
John John here's the deal you're going
to get access to this data but you can't
use it for these things you can't use it
for this and you can't use it for this
short definition user right and so as
soon as you get on the computer what
happens so you type in
I thought she screwed me over so bad but
we had returned there and all you
oh my god oh my god if you were caught
doing that then you would either be
removed or promoted No referred to the
Department of Justice as we did on
several of those cases let's talk about
Snowden what would you like Snowden to
know right now other than significantly
less I would like to set him down in a
classified setting and say you want to
see the damage you've done and lay that
out on the terrorists side and others so
he knows in his heart and he would have
to live with that the rest of his life
right but you're giving information to
the one man on earth
guaranteed to leak it is it any wonder
that Americans are concerned about your
judgment regarding their data well you
know you're asking ideally if we had a
way of sitting him down and that he's
not going to go leak more data and you
could show him do you understand what
you've done and from my perspective I
don't think he understands the true
damage that he's done right okay so
finally let's talk about branding the
NSA's brand has been damaged I think
that's fair to say right right as we
learned with Blackwater you don't have
to change the substance of anything that
you do as long as you visibly rebrand
okay so let's try this the Washington
Redskins it's a slightly less tainted
brand than yours yeah but they're
probably not a good one to go with sorry
okay no good how about this mr. tiggles
mr. tiggles is not just the mascot it's
also the name of the agency like Chucky
Cheese then a journalist can't say the
NSA is storing huge amount of data on
foreign countries instead of saying mr.
tiggles is storing huge amounts of data
in the boot isn't he clever Zenith boot
oh you've Bottomly overstepped your
bounds mr tickel's but I can't stay bad
you just want to keep me safe yeah and I
don't think that's gonna work
okay how about rebranding yourself as a
great listener the only agency in
government that really listens that's
what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying because in many
ways the NSA is the the perfect partner
so let me introduce you to the new na
say Trevor I think this is good tell us
about your day
everything about it how's Muhammad at
work how is he what's he been doing
Trevor so if you had to choose one of
these which would it be
well I think that's something that
perhaps you could have people vote on so
there you have it
at long last Americans are being allowed
to vote on something having to do with
the NSA just pick up your phone and call
any number and say a B or C into the
handset don't worry your vote will be
collected